I've never actually been to Chicago so
this is a first for me it's not cool man
it's not freezing man i generate heat
let's get on the plane
hello everyone it's time for me to
travel again I usually don't like
traveling that much takes me away but if
it's important and i feel like i have an
impact I like it note so this week I'm
heading off to Chicago for sage summit
I'm going to be doing a couple of
speeches on raising capital and
marketing as well as some hangouts with
Stephen Kelly and the whole bunch of
other fun stuff we'll see what happens
and you guys get to join me for the
journey I'm almost ready to go I like
making sure that Nina has a nice clean
place to come back to so you know that
the usual empty the dishwasher clean up
all that stuff left her a note last time
I left a note and she didn't see it I
had to tell her that I left a note cuz
she always misses me I name is her too
there's that note you see that bright
yellow thing she cannot miss the note so
just packing up I've got everything in
these two bags that I'm gonna need for
my trip alex is here working focused and
here's Nina saying I'm gonna miss you me
to check in at least a couple times a
day or Nina's gonna have serious
depression so I got it i jacked my list
to make sure don't laugh Alex so need to
get depressed Rosanna with me if we
don't see each other a lot she gets
angry this one she gets angry with me
and like hostile even though she misses
me and then I give her a hug you know
little kiss and it's all better she
melts but women react differently to
when they love someone they miss them
why we're gonna sweater Alex because I
will say why you keep this room below 58
Fahrenheit okay first of all I find the
ridiculous you should be in Celsius but
beside the point it's 58 so i can borrow
the sweater from you because wearing
jeans socks a t-shirt during the summer
it's still not enough and you're wearing
shorts and a t-shirt it's not cool man
it's not freezing man I'm just hot
blooded what can i say i generate heat
let's get to work in the cold Alex
finish packing up grab a cab and head to
the airport and see Chicago looking
forward to meeting some of you guys
there to YouTube needs to know Alex
heard his crap okay sweetheart my car
look at this point uh-huh you want to
take the elevator okay we'll take the
elevator let's call it things there's
not a lecture describes just on
principle now on principle I really not
gonna do it he's dangerous crotch even
more Jesus this is where do my stillroom
ranked at a stairwell friend the other
day it is this awesome friend it's fire
all right just arrived at the airport
passed out in the car nice relaxing
drive out here so rather than going in
refreshed let's get on the plane all
right I made it in got through customs
had to take off my shoes I have the
yellow ones now when i had the all-black
vibrams i can get by without taking off
my shoes that I with socks
so get hungry we're going to get some
food review my presentation i'm doing
obsession tomorrow on raising capital so
i'm going to put my slides one more time
I sure got it in good in that you're
into the bling first stop tim hortons
this is my first presentation region
we're about the board I got to get in
that long line
yeah baby Chicago here I come
so just landed in chicago of all the
places that i've been to in the u.s.
I've never actually been to Chicago so
this is the first for me one of the
things that I like doing as I talking
before when I travel is meeting up with
fans and scribers i'm just going to know
them see who those people are
face-to-face see who you guys are
face-to-face shake some hands when I
bought your business here I can help and
one of the things I experimented with
recently we figure where am I going
baggage claim i guess is having fans
pick me up and taking to the airport
usually before and i travel when i was
go I take a cab right take a cab to the
airport from the airport and so I
started trying something new where I
meet with you guys subscribers so Adam
one of my YouTube subscribers and
Twitter followers is going to pick me up
at the airport here and take them to my
hotel and we're going to chat about his
business all the way on the drive so I
get a ride he gets in free consulting I
get to meet a fan and everybody wins way
more fun than is taking a cat so I'm
going to look for Adam in exactly all
right I found that apparently Canada is
not international
next step I don't know why what's wrong
terminals here is Adam tell us about
yourself what do you do so I'm a Twitter
consultant I work with a couple of
clients
get the word out about people's company
on Twitter and where can you find you
I'm @ @ o Adam June on Twitter cool so
yeah I like it we're going to write the
hotel and talk some biz
alright well I was cool lots of fun good
talk took almost an hour to get into
town because of traffic but I was good
gave us chance to really chat it up and
learn more about his business gave us
some good advice I hope that will we
start off on one path one little project
and evolved into an entire new business
for him and I'm excited to see where he
goes I am here my hotel this is the
Palmer House so I'm going to go check in
and see what happens like these old
elevators all right 13th look boys 13th
whoop I think I'm in the wrong side
wrong side 13 is over here 13 13 13
let's see what we got here it's a
good-sized room queen bed nice looking
good so I'm gonna get set a little bit
take off my backpack and practice my
speech but I think first I'm gonna go
get some food I'm hungry it's what six
o'clock here which means it's seven
o'clock maybe it's 630 what time is it
oh it's seven o'clock Reuters eight
o'clock my time I haven't had dinner yet
food and then back home approximate
presentation I get this crazy idea on
the airplane for I'm going to do sup
I've never done a presentation before
I'll see if I still like it tomorrow and
have the guts to do it now that I said
that I have to do it we'll see them
we'll see how i feel in the morning yeah
so I got to eat so that red square is me
apparently I'm supposed to head up
what's the name of that street state
state street and down Michigan Avenue
and see the Magnificent Mile head across
the river that's the advice from the
concierge so going to give it a shot see
what I see its food
it's interesting that people don't
jaywalk here on the on the main streets
feel the chemical Depot's in New York I
just feel like I want to jaywalk
nobody's doing it so I feel like I
shouldn't I gotta act like the locals at
least until I I'm comfortable enough to
break the rules
why don't you
okay so north of the river people will j
watch like crazy but South they don't
I'm still trying to figure it out no but
it feels good to jaywalk again
so didn't find anything that really
appealed to me though I think I'm kind
of on the wrong streets for restaurants
and food and stuff
I gotta eat something and get back in
practice and maybe meet some people in
the lobby so I'm just going to go to
chipotle kind of boring but at least you
know it's good in relatively healthy so
he's food so they don't have Wi-Fi in
chipotle people they always had Wi-Fi
maybe it's just in Canada did you do I
don't know so I got it to go I got my
bag I got a steak bowl with the works in
the bag of chips with walk and I'm gonna
head back to my hotel had a pretty funky
blogging my hotel was feeling it lots of
work space so head back there pull out
my phone see if I can kept up Nina a
little bit tweeting maybe some work
while I eat and then head back to the
room and practice mice I'm like in
Chicago pretty nice night
and pretty scenic place I don't know
where that that silver beam is the beam
that silver thing that guy's an angry
cop that's silver thing everybody takes
pictures with I don't know where that is
but I don't really have a lot of time to
explore test it out top priority is to
rock the presentation tomorrow I'm here
to have an impact otherwise I'm wasting
my time so I got to make sure I'm on my
game super prepared and I got a chow
down and then practice practice practice
here we go got back to the room found
some nice stuff on my bed from Sage just
thank you what's inside I got some water
i meet that actually got some popcorn oh
nice I almost stopped at a popcorn place
so it's feeling some and what's this oh
it's a it's a brownie nice let's check
out the card thank you for speaking of
stage time i pleasing yours instructions
a token of our appreciation to this age
summit team feeling it all right time to
practice my speech get a good night's
sleep and wake up tomorrow and crush so
quick update for you guys practice the
speech superpump super excited super
happy um can't wait for tomorrow the
downside is there's this crazy screaming
baby next to me and it's been screaming
for a couple hours I think finally fell
asleep they can't move into a new room
because it's fully booked but they they
got me some your earplugs that i'm gonna
guess try out hopefully hopefully the
baby does not cry so i get a good sleep
a bunch of you guys ordered books which
I'm super grateful for and so the last
thing I'm going to do before hitting the
bed is record some Thank You videos
because that was one of the bonuses and
I just really appreciate all you guys
who are willing to kind of period or
book preorder a book now is coming out
in December I mean you get a lot of cool
bonuses alongside it but really
appreciate the support so I'm going to
record some videos Eric how you doing
brother I'm here and should come
with 11 15 p.m. what's up Rishi thank
you so much for ordering the book it
means a lot to me hey Zeno just wanted
to do a quick video to thank you for
buying the book pre-ordering it means a
lot to me all right that's it Nina just
came online so I'm gonna say a quick
goodnight to her and then hit the bed
wake up tomorrow to rock it